[Music]
[Applause]
luno the fastest easiest way to buy
bitcoin
if you're just getting into crypto it's
the perfect place to start hey guys anna
welcome back to my show i'm super
excited to chat to you all
we had a week off but we're back so it's
gonna be really exciting so as always as
you know
it is powered by icon plus capital so a
quick news update for you so actually on
april the 25th icons d5 platform balance
will be released a user-friendly
platform that creates ics tokens pegged
to real-world assets
like the dollar light gold and like oil
now before we jump
into this because this one's going to be
very exciting um
this is sponsored by block by you can
actually get up to 250
and when you sign up with them i use
them get up to 8.6
interest on your ustc pretty cool all
right so
let's bring on today's guest joining me
today is muneeb
ali how are you doing today i'm good
thanks thanks for having me
yeah i'm really excited to chat to you
um because
this topic is fascinating to me
because you have these two worlds right
you've got like this narrative that
bitcoins this store of value
and then you've got d5 and everything
that's going on there
but that's not quite the case is it
because you're trying to essentially
bring that
onto this side you're trying to you know
do smart contracts define everything on
bitcoin so talk to me about this
yeah so i think i think there's there's
a big misconception out there
that uh bitcoin is like a hard rock and
it can't do anything interesting
like in like if you think about it
bitcoin
has a blockchain where the original
designers have taken certain design
decisions
to keep it relatively simple at the base
layer
and that's completely fine because you
can build the rest of the functionality
outside of the core bitcoin blockchain
right like their tools come to mind with
sidechains and other other type of
technologies so it's just a kind of like
a technical design decision that do you
really want to do it at the base there
or do you want to do it like around the
base layer
uh and we bring smart contracts to
bitcoin by not modifying bitcoin
at all but uh basically
building a separate system stacks that
connects to bitcoin that settles
transactions on bitcoin
and brings smart contracts there and if
you compare that to other systems like
ethereum and other ecosystems
uh over there they would have more
native
support for smart contracts right at the
base layer but that's just like a
technical detail there's nothing
fundamental about doing it this way or
that way
a lot of the time when we talk about um
building this kind of ecosystem
on top of bitcoin there's a huge
criticism
that you know it would mean compromising
security decentralization but
i'm assuming that isn't the case because
you're not changing the actual
fundamental
technology yes so i think uh
so i i have a distributed systems uh
background so i've been i've been
kind of like doing research work in this
area for for more than a decade and so
and uh discovered bitcoin around 2013
and even from back then it was
abundantly clear
that you can't scale the base layer
to do millions of transactions or store
like an insane amount of data there
or to have full smart contracts at the
base layer because you open for smart
contracts
especially with like you know full
tiering complete languages you're
opening yourself
up to certain attack factors that you
really don't want at the
at the basic and similarly like the
bitcoin blockchain is not a place to
store user data
or to store like tons of information and
we saw that in the
um in in the big blocks small block type
of wars right like people who forked off
who wanted to basically store a lot of
data in the bitcoin blockchain that that
doesn't really work that way right
bitcoin is really a
settlement layer only the most important
transactions are going to happen on
bitcoin
it is a store of value and just like the
lightning network
settles a lot of uh transactions
directly on the bitcoin function
the stacks blockchain does the same
thing right so you can do thousands or
potentially down the road millions of
transactions on stacks
and they would just set you on bitcoin
but they're benefiting from the security
of the base layer
which is the critical thing to
understand here right because everything
that is settling on bitcoin
is benefiting from the proof of work
from the security
of the bitcoin blockchain because once
that transaction settles on bitcoin like
you would have to
go and reorg bitcoin to be able to
change the history of that
right so those are the the benefits and
at a high level uh bitcoin by far
is the biggest brand name uh it has the
largest community
it has over a trillion dollars of crypto
capital and most people are going to get
introduced to
crypto through bitcoin like bitcoin is
the first thing that they uh that they
hear about
and then interestingly you know
developers would be like oh i can't
really program bitcoin at the base layer
and then they would discover ethereum or
some other blockchain but
99 of the developers have never written
a smart contract yet right so
the future developers would discover
bitcoin and then be like oh cool i can
also program bitcoin here are a bunch of
different options there are some
programming languages
and i think that's that that's kind of
like my my vision of the world of like
where
where things go but if you're just
building
on top of it right and so you ha you
have the
bitcoin network which maintains the
security so that's not changing
and you can rely on that what you're
building on top
how do we know that that is secure and
the reason i ask this
is because one of the biggest um
criticisms of everything that isn't
bitcoin is just the fact that it's not
proof of work and it's not bitcoin and
it's just not bitcoin right
and that's kind of what what it comes
down to so
this is another layer of technology that
isn't bitcoin so how can we trust it why
is it not
why is it not the same as you know
another layer on top of ethereum
given i know obviously the ethereum
layer one is different
yeah so i think think of this way that
theoretically
we could have started a separate layer
one proof-of-work network which is
actually what ethereum did
right like ethereum started the separate
google work network and now you have a
different set of miners who are doing
proof of work on bitcoin
and a different set of miners with a
different algorithm for for the
for the hashes that they're calculating
for doing proof of work uh
on ethereum and ethereum has plans for
moving to proof of stake and so on and
we can we can
we can separate that out but
fundamentally speaking you're actually
not sharing the compute power of bitcoin
you're you're starting a separate
network and this is the this is the
exact thing that we wanted to avoid
in the sense that what we have figured
out is consensus
between blockchains right now usually a
blockchain system would just have
consensus on at
a single blockchain level so we figured
out a consensus protocol between
two blockchains between bitcoin and
stacks and what happens is that our
uh stacks is completely dependent on
bitcoin for for survival right like we
are we are not competing with bitcoin
we are not trying to be money uh this
tax cryptocurrency
is a uh asset that is used as gas uh for
smart contracts
right and it completely depends on
bitcoin for even survival
and our miners work on the bitcoin chain
right so instead of doing
proof of work they are actually uh
we have a new mechanism called proof of
transfer
where it's like they're using bitcoin to
secure
this tax chain right so it's a little
bit like you've already produced bitcoin
by doing proof of work
now just use the bitcoin as as almost
like proof of computation
and use that to secure a blockchain that
kind of like depends on on bitcoin
but the the critical difference here is
uh once the transactions
settle on bitcoin you would have to go
and reorg bitcoin uh to be able to
change that history
right whereas if you had a separate
system then
the security of the blockchain really
depends on the security of that
completely separate uh separate system
in blockchain you have nothing to do
with bitcoin
at that point and obviously the
lightning network is very much
to do with literally just speeding up
transactions so would you say that
what you're doing is similar to that
just with more added features
essentially
yes it is very similar in design and uh
so people who understand lightning
network think of it this way that you
have to set up
uh the nodes in a lightning channel and
then you can actually do fast
transactions and that at some point the
channel is going to go and settle on
bitcoin
so the way we design stacks is uh that
that there are miners who are
effectively
they already have these channels open
all the time
and they're settling by default every
single bitcoin block so every single
bitcoin block
all the transactions that happen on the
stack side they automatically set on a
bitcoin so you don't have to worry about
who's setting up the channels who's
actually going to settle
on on the chain and then the biggest
difference is actually the clarity smart
contract programming language
so clarity is a new smart contract
programming language that has full
visibility into bitcoin
meaning that you can developers can
start building smart contracts
uh where they're actually programming
against bitcoin state which is super
exciting because you know bitcoin is
a trillion dollars in capital and i
think i think uh developers would want
to do very very interesting things for
them
so how are you then different because
you have some competitors out there
and there's rsk there's liquid btc
so what's the difference there
yeah so i think first of all like i'm a
i'm a bitcoiner at heart
and yeah i love all these different
efforts because in my mind these are
different
design points that people are exploring
so in terms of rsk
i think they are more in the camp of
trying to be a really
true side chain in the sense that they
don't have a separate
uh asset for for gas and transactions
and they're
focusing on trying to move bitcoin from
the bitcoin chain
using that as as the asset and then and
bringing that back
right so liquid is also more in that cam
uh you have
so so rska does uh merge mining right so
a subset of
the bitcoin miners would actually also
mine on the rsk chain
and in terms of of liquid they have a
slightly different design so they also
have a peg asset called uh called liquid
bdc and uh you can you can transfer that
into the liquid chain but on the way
back you have to trust a federation
right so it's like a somewhat of a semi
federated model
where where uh to get the bitcoin back
from liquid chain into the
into the bitcoin blockchain you have to
kind of trust the figuration and and
again i'm not that's going to be some
yes but these are these are different
design choices right so people whoever
feel comfortable with whatever
design choice like for example i
understand that
that some people in the bitcoin
community are not going to like the fact
that stacks has a different asset
right yeah if you want to be if you want
to be very much on one end of the
spectrum that you believe in just one
asset
maybe you would uh you would be more uh
inclined to use a network where there's
no other asset but but
interesting i have a question on that
point though i have a question on that
point though so
if so why do you have why do you have
your own asset i know you said for
gatsbys but is it even possible
you know i'm not super techy i don't
know is it possible to do what you're
doing
without that it can you not just be
bitcoin only in it
exactly so i think these are the
trade-offs right that because we have
the new asset our mining is actually
permissionless
you don't have to rely on a on a
federation
because miners have incentives right so
mining is permissionless
secondly these miners have incentives to
store the extra
smart contract state you don't want to
put
that data the smart contract logic into
the bitcoin blockchain itself
right so because of the stacks asset
these miners have an incentive
to store that data right and keep that
data alive
and finally that is the asset that is
being used for gas
so you have to whenever whenever you're
asking another party to do
computations for you you have to
basically pay them right
and that payment is in is in stacks and
if you were trying to make it in bitcoin
like my like it would actually be
extremely expensive right like bitcoin
is
is is a very expensive asset and we have
actually tried that some earlier
versions of our system
were directly trying to build on top of
bitcoin directly trying to
actually use bitcoin as the asset and
very quickly you were in situations
where
let's say you're trying to register a
three dollar domain name
and you're paying a 50 bucks in in
transaction fees on that three dollar of
worth of transactions right
and also the bitcoin core developers
would hate the fact that now you're
storing all that additional data into
the bitcoin blockchain itself
right so we revise our design and the
sax blockchain that launched
two months ago uh actually does not make
any changes to bitcoin at all
does not write any additional data uh on
the bitcoin side
and and effectively you can do cheap
transactions that are
that are they're settling on bitcoin
automatically
so what would you say the main reason
for doing this is then because
right now we have d5 okay so ethereum is
is slightly broken potentially we've got
82.0 coming at some point one day
but you know this finance smart chain a
lot there's been a massive
um you know migration and move to bsc
so right now bitcoin has really adopted
that store of value narrative i mean
people like elon musk and michael saylor
they're not
buying into bitcoin for any d5 purposes
they're buying into bitcoin
because it's gold 2.0 so is this
necessary like why of course it's
necessary because you're doing it but
why is why would you say it's necessary
why can't you just leave it as it is
and let finance do as they're doing and
all the other
you know projects polkadot and so on
yeah no
that's a great question so i think let's
let's play it out uh
bitcoin is kind of like winning the sort
of value uh use case
so let's say we start getting more and
more capital right now we're at one
trillion maybe it goes to two trillion
three
trillion and right and that's saved as
bitcoin now people want to do useful
things with that capital
and what you're noticing is that people
would have things like uh synthetic
bitcoin assets
like wrapped bitcoin and they're so in
in
wrapped bitcoin let's look at the user
flow first of all there's a custodian in
the middle
uh so you're getting a tax hit when
you're going from bitcoin to wrapped
bitcoin and then back
you're actually now introducing a tech
stack that maybe bitcoiners don't want
to trust
because now rap bitcoin is being issued
on top of a theory right so in some ways
they're taking a tax head they're going
through a custodial and now
their asset is on on a technology stack
that they might consider
to be too experimental uh and and
they're taking additional risk there
versus imagine that a bitcoin lending
application
where uh built on stacks because tax is
doing the reverse of that instead of
taking an
asset to a different blockchain it's
bringing the smart contracts to bitcoin
right so once you have smart contracts
on bitcoin directly uh you can have a
lending application
where your bitcoin is just going from a
pure bitcoin address
to another pure bitcoin address on the
main chain as the as
as the lending side of it and the smart
contract logic lives on the stack side
that has a collateral
and can release the collateral
automatically if your loan doesn't come
back
so i think it actually reduces a lot of
complexity uh it's a much more simpler
approach
and it it cuts out a lot of the the
custodians or risk factors and other
other blockchains so i think
the model to think about really here is
that once you have so much capital
locked up as bitcoin
people would want to do interesting
things with it like they would want to
have bitcoin lending they would want to
deploy that capital
uh to provide liquidity or have other
other types of use cases
and what we're doing is we're basically
bringing the use cases to bitcoin
treating bitcoin as a center of gravity
versus being in this weird
sort of a world where people are trying
to issue synthetic assets
uh on on top of other chains right and
you you mentioned a couple of efforts
there
i would also like to point out that
there's also a bitcoin
way of building things right where a
bitcoin way did you say
a bitcoin way of doing yeah like like
like if you look at the bitcoin stack
uh the the quality bar for for
for the technology is actually very very
high right people are
very much concerned about the security
of the code base they're very concerned
about
uh you know consensus issues and so on
so whenever you're
you're adding something more
experimental to the mix
it will actually give pause to a lot of
bitcoiners that they might not want to
use that technology
so with with stacks one thing that we're
really trying to do is
we're trying to focus a lot on these
things that we
we use bitcoin as much as possible for
security uh
our smart contract language is actually
uh you can have formal proofs of
verification there
so so people can feel feel safe that
this contract can only do what it's
supposed to do and can't do anything
else
and and best of all it's a
permissionless system right so you
mentioned the binance smart contracts
there are like 15 or so nodes that it's
it's again a federated network they're
15 or so nodes that are controlling that
finance smart chain
and i think that might not go that well
with a lot of bitcoiners
who are are believers in in
decentralization and permissionless
things and
and basically doing things uh that that
are
more clearly on one end of the spectrum
yeah i think that's a massive um
criticism
of uh binary smart chain that i keep
hearing even in comparison to
to ethereum but okay so everything that
we're seeing right now is taking time
especially with eats 2.0
um and i really feel there's there's
some there's just huge competition
there's a lot of talk um obviously i was
doing a lot of research about stacks
before
our interview there's a lot of talk
about whether you guys are looking to
replace ethereum
but you're not looking to replace
ethereum are you
yeah i would i would say that there is
some overlap but there is definitely a
lot of a lot of green field as well
like for example there are certain
applications that are possible on stacks
that are simply not possible on popular
theory right i'll give you
one example yeah uh so we have this uh
px contract
where people can lock up lock-up capital
and they're earning bitcoin
as a yield and these are pure bitcoin
transactions on the bitcoin
blockchain so people you if you lock up
capital there like you
are actually getting a bitcoin yield and
it's around 10
so we launched around two months ago and
over that time
uh we first got 100 million uh total
value locked and 200 then 300 then 400
and i think last week it crossed a
billion dollars right so within two
months we are actually seeing
uh traction on a smart contract where
people can lock up capital and earn
bitcoin
and these types of functionality would
be impossible or at least very very hard
to do on blockchains
that are separate from bitcoin and that
are not kind of like directly building
on top
and that's just one use case imagine
different types of bitcoin yields
different types of stable coins that are
actually backed by bitcoin that actually
settle on bitcoin and so on
so i would say there is a lot of green
field of innovation
directly on top of bitcoin where we are
not competing with it with ethereum or
other chains
and then there are overlapping areas
like for example
if someone is trying to issue nfts uh on
the edm chain well you can do that
on on top of bitcoin now through two
stacks and so on and
there would be a subset of these
applications i think ethereum is it will
it is likely going to survive in one
form and another for years to come
uh i've been a skeptic of e2 purely from
a computer science uh
like technical design perspective and i
think they have morphed the design
several times it still keeps changing
although there's a lot of kind of like
marketing hype
around it and people are getting excited
as if uh e2 is about to happen but i
think it's it's years and years
out and it is not in its final form uh
at all at this point
yeah not at all but so what's the
reception been um from the bitcoin
community i've been really fascinated
because when we had that whole d5 summer
uh but people were just sort of saying
you know bitcoin as melee was saying d5
is just a scam
um but i wonder whether they don't feel
that way now that it's sort of
going to be built on top of bitcoin i
don't know what's the reception been
yeah so i think uh i would i would
separate separate out two things one is
um
useful things you can do with
decentralized finance
i think that actually a lot of
bitcoiners would like that like why do i
need to depend on a bank or a financial
institution
for for taking a loan out like imagine a
bitcoiner is like hey i want to give
bitcoin collateral
and i want to take out a stable currency
like a usdc
loan right use it and then give it back
because i don't want to sell my bitcoin
that's defy but that's the kind of d5
that they're going to love
that yes i don't don't want to sell
bitcoin i'm not trusting anyone
and you know i'm taking a loan loan from
a from from a smart contract or the
other way around that i want to lend out
my bitcoin in a trustless way
and earn interest on it because i don't
want to sell my bitcoin
right so these are all d5 applications
and and bitcoiners would like the
decentralization aspect of it
i think where they get more hung up is
sometimes the
more experimental nature of things on
ethereum or other systems or
the kind of like the marketing and the
hype around some of the these
these new assets and how it's it feels a
little bit like gambling
and i think that's where uh there's a
almost like a cult
like a cultural reaction that hey we
don't like that type of activity
and we would just rather stay out of it
i don't but i don't think that
uh if you talk about like useful
applications that are decentralizing
finance like they are quite appealing to
to a lot of bitcoiners and interestingly
i'll mention something
so i think overall i would say the
reception for stacks since the launch
two two months or so ago has been really
well there are obviously
uh bitcoin hardliners who just don't who
are very skeptical of any new type of an
asset like doesn't matter what that
asset is they just don't like it and
interestingly
uh sometimes people would be skeptical
of the stacks asset when you need it
and you would have to get into a
discussion like the one we did that it
actually ensures permission that's
mining
it gives incentives for miners to keep
that data because you do want to keep
that data outside of bitcoin
and and so on but then they would have
like some sort of uh
some sort of a moment where they're like
okay it's a new asset i generally don't
like new assets but this asset
earns bitcoin right i do want to earn
bitcoin though right so they would have
like that moment where
where they would actually uh start
getting more curious and start
start learning more more about the
project so there's a bit that i'm still
not 100 on which i just want to get
right in my head because
you you made a tweet the other day and
you also spoke about it just now the the
idea of
lending with bitcoin so i love that
because i'm one of those people that
will
never sell their bitcoin dad asks me
what my pension plan is i say it's
bitcoin like that's that's a serious
conversation we're having
um but you said there's no counterparty
risk you just have to trust the network
but how can we trust the network because
it's not because i
i know of course we've got the bitcoin
base layer but how can we trust the
stacks network
sure you know because it's not bitcoin
yes that's
what i can't get my head around the the
way to think about this is
that any system that's kind of like an
extension of bitcoin
yes it introduces some risks but you can
understand
but you can understand those risks like
for example if you're using the
lightning channel
you can try to understand what what my
risks are and what would happen
if things go wrong right so this is
where stax comes
in and why we focused a lot on the
clarity smart contract language
uh so the clarity language has formal
verification
meaning that if you're doing uh let's
say there's a lending application built
built uh both using it so you're lending
your bitcoin
and what you're trusting it that here's
a smart contract
that has let's say 200 collateralized
uh some sort of a stable coin called a
usdc loan
so your risk factor is that if by a
certain bitcoin block
my bitcoin doesn't come back
is the collateral going to automatically
release to me or not
right and you can have formal
verifications that yes
this smart contract will release you
know usdc to you
if if your if your bitcoin doesn't come
back because this smartphone rack
actually has full visibility into
bitcoin
you're actually trusting the bitcoin
state so the smart contract knows about
bitcoin blocks
the smart contract knows about when
money moves on bitcoin
right so the logic in the smart contract
is saying if bitcoin x amount of bitcoin
does not come back to this address
by this block number the smart contract
is going to release
the collateral to your address and then
you can go and buy
buy more bitcoin you mentioned
um nfts earlier and i really want to
talk about that because obviously
that's going to be part of all of this
but before we go into that where do you
stand on nfts because
i think the the hype is slowly dying
down um
of course bitcoiners don't like it um
so so where do you stand do you think
it's a bubble or do you think there's
some actual value there
i think i think there is definitely a
lot of
hype around it but uh i i think there's
definitely signal
amongst all of the noise like there are
some very interesting real applications
and i am one of those people who always
want to focus on the signal and kind of
like ignore the noise the noise is going
to go away at some point
interestingly the interesting thing
about nfts is that
nfts are actually a very old concept
like i'm actually seeing some
some talk in circles that nfts were
invented on ethereum and i'm like
scratching my head
because uh domain names are nfts
like non-fungible tokens and the very
first fork of bitcoin namecoin
i've actually worked on it i'm i'm i'm
og enough in this space that i
actually have hacked on namecoin i've
worked on the endpoint this is like
2013.
and namecoin was effectively a fork of
bitcoin introducing nfts and those nfts
were
uh domain names right and then we have
seen things like counterparty on bitcoin
where we had rare pepes and other types
of entities on top of the bitcoin chain
and some of the difficulties with these
things i think those challenges are
still there for example namecoin was a
merged mind chain with bitcoin
again those types of questions that do
you want to share the compute power of
the bitcoin do you want to build this
separate network
and and with counterparty you were
actually storing a lot of information on
the main bitcoin chain
and it was a bit clunky and so on and
early days i think it's the same set of
underlying technical challenges
that in many ways like we work on with
stacks where
we're like okay this thing is not merged
mine this thing is permissionless
uh you are not storing the data on the
bitcoin chain and you can have nfts you
can have domain names uh
you can have other types of digital art
and that is secured by bitcoin
when you're talking about nfts and their
ownership and their provenance
uh like what better way to store the
ownership information than the bitcoin
blockchain that's going to be
there uh a hundred years from now and so
on right and and you don't want to
uh kind of like become a scalability
problem for the bitcoin blockchain
that's why
you want to settle uh thousands of
transactions on bitcoin in a single
transaction
instead of like every time there's a
sale of an nft
you're paying like a hundred dollars on
the main blockchain to actually record
that information
but you didn't tell me i don't know do
you think it's a bubble or do you think
there's genuine value i think
i think they're uh in the long term
there's genuine value
right in the short term we might be in a
bubble where a lot of people who have
kind of like formered into nfts
when the markets turn a little bit they
would realize that they're holding
highly illiquid assets
and and the prices have actually gone
down and nobody's willing to buy these
things
so i think the the way to think about
this is i am very bullish on the
underlying technology in future use
cases uh but i definitely think that in
the short term there there there's a
bubble and
you know it's gonna it's gonna burst or
something
yeah i think it's a really interesting
one because i've always said
i can see value in it just given
everything
is gone digital it just makes sense that
even physical
items would have some kind of tokenized
um identity on the blockchain just to
verify whether it be
um you know like a designer handbag or a
watch or whatever it is you know
ornaments just to give an actual you
know you can track the whole supply
chain to me i find value in that the
whole bubble that's kind of where i'm
not sure about
yeah i mean they're they're already
things online like i think domain names
are actually a perfect example
it's a purely digital asset has nothing
to do with the real world it has value
like domain names have been around for
decades now people pay
a lot of money for for domain names
domain names are
nfts they and similarly if you look at
a lot of games any in-game asset
is actually an nft it could very easily
be converted to an nft and people are
paying money for these things like
they're they're paying money to get an
avatar in a video game they're paying
money to actually
buy and resell things and what nfts kind
of like do is that they
define ownership at a global scale so
you can actually take things from one
video game
sell it on a secondary market somewhere
outside and that's a that's a that's a
pretty pretty kind of like a huge market
and i also wanted to learn a little bit
more about you
on a more casual level like how did you
get into crypto where did your journey
start
yeah it's interesting actually uh
yesterday a friend of mine sent me a
clip
of a talk i was giving at the
at the princeton club here in new york
it was in 2014
i think there were some uh uh comments
there where i was telling people that
i am 100 in bitcoin like i actually cash
out
to uh eat right like and in 2014 in
hindsight like that turned out to be a
really good decision
but my journey has been that uh i'm i'm
a computer scientist
i did my phd at princeton and i have
always been working
on uh internet protocols like next
generation internet protocols
cloud computing uh like high scalability
distributed systems and so on
and i was actually working originally on
almost like a next generation internet
architecture there have been many such
efforts in academia at princeton
stanford and other places
but none of them got commercialized and
that really bothered me right so i
wanted to
almost like build this thing out as a
commercial entity
that what would a future more secure
more decentralized internet look like
and discovered blockchains on the way
right so this is this is 2013
when uh me and my co-founder we
discovered uh blockchains and that
fundamental question of
should we build on bitcoin should we
build on namecoin which is like a
merge mine chain or three should we
start a separate blockchain
your camera's gone a little bit
is it is it better oh i think we're back
all right yeah
yeah very good yeah sorry go on yeah so
i think that that
question of like you know should you
build directly on bitcoin should you
work on a merge line chain like name
coin or three should you go off and
start a separate block
i think that is literally still the
question that people are asking even
right now
that hey should you build on bitcoin
should you build on ethereum which is a
separate chain
or should you build on something
something like rsk which is which is
merged
right and i think i think uh over there
over the years from the lessons that we
have learned i think we have
uh we are pretty much in the camp that
there will be more experimentation in
the short term there will be many
different blockchains many different
types of experiments
but in the long term i think we'll see
consolidation on top of bitcoin
and that's that's our core thesis that
any
uh any application or smart contract
that actually
finds a product market fit will
eventually exist in some form
on top of bitcoin which is the bigger
market and more more secure
i think what really fascinates me about
all of this is the fact that it is just
so experimental
and i've been following um rao powell's
kind of
interaction and journey through this
space
um because i think at one point he was
90 in bitcoin 80
in eth and now he's really delved into
many other different things
and he's very much of the mindset which
i i sort of i do share this mindset i
for me bitcoin is number one and i just
won't sell it
it's just not happening um but i am
interested in all sorts of other
innovation that's happening and i think
that
we have to i don't i'm not i just i
think it's just
reductionist to be so close-minded and
not and not
open your eyes and see what else is
coming along it doesn't mean that what
else is coming on
along is necessarily going to replace
bitcoin or be better but i just think
everything is so early we always go on
about how early everything is
and how early we are and we just don't
know what's coming next so i just
feel that we i i'm open to seeing
everything and hearing about all the
different projects and seeing
you know what comes of it
yeah i think definitely like humans are
curious-minded people right so
even if you're like i've i've i've
pretty much been in the bitcoin
camp since the beginning but i've kept
kept like a small
pocket i've called it like five percent
10 experimentation
especially if they're people that like
and trust and they're trying to do
something
interesting like like juan at fault coin
is is a colleague of mine
i like i would i would i would back them
right i'll see like what happens it's a
it's an interesting ambitious project
let's see let's see what happens over
there but i think the this mentality of
actually uh like bitcoiners i can see
their point of view as well
like they've actually seen the story
play out several times over
like whenever you're in a bull market
uh sometimes the more experimental
things end up getting more attention
because they're very risky but they
might be maybe showing better returns
right like safe moon you remember you
saw
moonlight like that that was wild yeah i
heard heard some things about it but
but then given a long enough timeline
like
these more experimental things then
crash very hard as well
right so if you have actually lost
bitcoin
in kind of like trading these assets
like you
uh you you have those those scars right
and you want to be extremely careful of
uh of engaging there
yeah and i i totally get that um i i
just think that
the hostility is is quite unbelievable
um so it always blows my mind but listen
i'm wondering we have a lot of questions
coming through
so i'm wondering whether you'd be open
to do a quick ama
um if i throw some questions on the
screen yep
happy too all right cool so guys if you
do have any questions then
just drop them below in the chat now
because we're gonna answer some of them
so
i'm just gonna go through i think my
wi-fi is cutting in and out maybe i
don't know
um but here we go let's have a look
is he okay having jack associated with
their project is jack associated with
your project
ceo jack yeah jack is not a investor
in the project but i have connected with
him on twitter he's a bitcoiner he's
very excited about seeing more
innovation on bitcoin but he's
officially i don't think he's a
uh he is a measure of the product okay
someone has also asked um about hiro
they've said that they're excited about
the platform if you can give any
updates on that yes so i think
uh my company did the early r d and
public infrastructure building
and once we launched the the stacks 2.0
blockchain
two three months ago we clearly
separated out the open
source project uh stacks from my company
right so my company focuses on developer
tools for
for uh for the system and what we're
doing is effectively building out all
the developer tools that people would
need
and the and the latest version that we
announced today the
the hero platform it's meant to be a
hosted service
that makes it super easy for developers
to uh deploy apps and smart contracts on
top of stacks and bitcoin
right so think of it that the underlying
network is open and decent life
but we want to make lives or developers
as easy as possible give them all the
right tools the apis
uh to make it super simple to build
built on top of bitcoin
and this one's fun so could we give a
tip about the next game changer in
crypto so i actually asked my community
this the other day
we've had icos we've had d5
we've had nfts what earth do you think
is next
yeah so i think i think interestingly i
would say
that my experience in crypto has been
that
there are ideas that are around for a
while but
the conditions are not right for them to
kind of take off i think nfts are a
great example they're by far
not a new thing like they've been around
for years and years
but suddenly the market conditions were
right for them to kind of like
go mainstream uh similarly i think
uh decent by social networks or or
decentralized identity
it's an idea that has been around in
crypto again like five six years now
but it might be that there is there are
some market conditions like down the
road i don't know if it's going to be
next year
a couple of years from now where
suddenly uh it just feels like
oh my god everyone is moving to a crypto
social network everyone is
everyone now has their own kind of like
crypto identity
and they're kind of like moving away
from the facebooks of the world like
that that would be one
one of the things that i would like
watch out for
so that's really interesting i'm so torn
when it comes to
um when it comes to those sorts of
things so decentralized
social media applications because we're
trying to do that um with
there are quite a few but it's so hard
to bring
people over isn't it um number one
people won't want to pay
for for content you know they want it
free twitter's free instagram facebook
youtube is all basically free
because we're the product um and i i
just
it's hard to bring people over and with
user experience not being so great i
mean hive wasn't the easiest of user
experiences you know just as an example
it just wasn't
um how likely do you think that actually
is you know
because user experience matters yes i
think there are there are several
challenges uh ux is one of them
uh i think it's also kind of like
network effects as well
like what incentives do people have to
move over but i think like the same
same thing with with some of the other
other stuff right like even the d5
it's like a marketplace like you need to
have liquidity you need to have the
right right protocols you need to have
enough of
incentives for people who can like move
over but once the stars line up
and i think there has been slow and
steady progress suddenly
it feels like oh this happened overnight
but that thing actually didn't happen
overnight it was like years and years
and years of
work in different directions when it
finally clicked and i think it's
entirely possible that
a decent life social network comes
around a couple of years from now
when the ux challenges have been solved
when
the incentivization uh is actually like
like like much better
understood that why would people move
over and and more more importantly why
would people move over with their
distribution and networks
intact right so it's actually better for
them like
when the content creators switch over
because they're making more money
on a decentralized social network than a
centralized one like i think they will
pull their their distribution with them
right and i i don't know what that
magic moment is like but i can see the
slow and steady progress towards
over the years and just final question
for you then
um bitcoin price i have to ask you when
you don't have to give us a prediction i
won't put the pressure on you but
what are your thoughts on the general
market because right now
i'm looking at the price about 40 54
sorry 0.5
a lot of people say that we are slowly
parachuting down now
we're not going to have a sharp snapback
we're slowly parachuting down a lot of
people say well also let's say about 60
of the way through the bull market where
do you think we're at right now
yeah so i think interestingly um
like i'm i'm buying more bitcoin like i
have buy orders yes
at 50 000 and so on i've been i've been
buying since bitcoin was 90
so i'm a long-term holder and
uh to me it doesn't feel like we're at
the end of this
this bull market again this is just not
investment advice this is just my
personal observations uh i i wouldn't be
surprised if we see a hundred thousand
uh bitcoin in this bull market like i i
do have the
the laser eyes on on my twitter but uh
but from
i'm just sharing what i personally do
like i'm buying at 50
and uh you know if you cross 100k that
would feel like okay that was a lot of
progress
for a single single cycle
yeah absolutely i think we're kind of at
a strange point
in in the cycle where a lot of people
i don't know we don't know where where
it's going i also feel i have i
i sort of gauge a sentiment that we're
around 60 70 the way through this bull
market
i'm still hoping for 100k this year um
but
but we'll see um manipu so where can
people find you
um what are you working on um just tell
us about yourself
and where they can find you yeah so i
think i'm i'm fairly active on twitter
uh i'm at the neeb m-u-n-e-e-b
and for people who want to learn more
about smart contracts for bitcoin
they can go to stacks dot co and stacks
is a
open source project there are actually
several entities behind it
and then you can learn about all the
different work that these different
entities are doing and the different app
developers and the
interesting things that they're building
on top of bitcoin
manip i want to thank you so much it's
been really interesting i've been so
fascinated about this entire topic um
especially because i've been spending a
lot of time in clubhouse rooms and you
really gauge the i don't know if you so
much time on there um
but you gauge the the maximalism um
so i i've been i've been interested to
see uh what's happening basically on
bitcoin
yeah clubhouse is great and it's great
to connect with the bitcoin community
there
yeah absolutely thank you so much for
coming on and guys thank you so much for
watching thank you to the sponsors block
find luno and
um icon plus of course and we will see
you all next week
bye awesome thanks for having me bye